des gerbes de fleurs déposées lui minute
de silence ce lundi soir les élus de la
ville de guyancourt et des anciens
combattants de la guerre d'algérie ont
partagé un moment de recueillement à
l'occasion du 56e anniversaire du
cessez-le-feu de ce conflit à
l'affrontement qui aura duré sept ans et
tué près de 300 mille personnes on
oublie trop ceux qui sont restés là bas
c'est pour ça donc on est quelques
accords à y penser mais lorsque vous
avez vécu cette partie là le cortège
s'est rendu dans deux lieux symboliques
de la commune la rue du 19 mars 1962 le
monument aux morts objectif transmettre
et partager le souvenir les
commémorations en général elles ont un
aspect pédagogique extrêmement important
alors évidemment la commémoration du 11
novembre celle du i mais celle de 2,2
d'aujourd'hui notamment dans sa
dimension intergénérationnelle de
transmission et c'est pour ça qu'on on y
tient très fortement sur la ville de mu
en cours les commémorations se sont
conclus par les discours il marseillaise
devant les anciens combattants
[Musique]